well a new bill in florida aims to stop
teachers from discussing sex and gender
identity with young children and not
like 8th graders like kindergarteners
the bill in the florida senate covers
well kindergartners through third grade
but you're probably not hearing that
from
your local news organization they'll
telling they're calling this the don't
say gay bill as if it's banning
conversation about
gay people or sex
here's what they're saying
in your view is this dangerous
legislation
absolutely yeah and and the reason is
that it uh tells uh youths who are
different or whose families are
different that there's something wrong
with him out of the gate he wants to uh
really say that florida is a free state
but it's only free if you act like him
look like him in a republican or where
you're a cis gender uh heterosexual
white republican man you know this falls
under the rubric of parental rights
legislation right and it started with
crt let's remember that if you start
coming after black people what comes
next right
of course the lgbtq house community and
then women and then other marginalized
groups
so the main trade route between southern
canada and michigan the bridge is shut
down right now hundreds of millions of
dollars
stopped on the bridge
and our transportation secretary is on
tv
complaining about a bill in the florida
legislature
that would prevent kindergartners from
learning about sex misplaced priorities
anyone
chadwick moore has been following all of
this he's the editor-in-chief of
outspoken he knows what's in the bill
because he's actually read it he joins
us tonight trebek moore thanks so much
for coming on the hysteria about this
seems a little calculated no
yeah look if wacky gay activists
childless wacky gay activists want to
drive
the white house the democrat party gay
media like cnn into this arena of
demonizing concerned parents after what
happened in virginia last year this year
now in the with the midterms coming up i
mean more power to them it's a terrible
look and like you had mentioned the bill
is four pages long all right no democrat
has read it uh and if they have they
don't want you to read it the media
doesn't want you to read it because when
you do you realize it's perfectly
reasonable rational bill that would not
even be necessary if parents didn't
become so privy to the insane things
their teachers were
saying to their students during lockdown
during remote learning this bill says
basically you can't have classroom-wide
discussions
from five to eight-year-olds about
gender identity and sexual orientation
um you can have one-on-one discussions
uh kids can talk about what they will
and ask questions about what they will
but you can't have discussions with
five-year-olds about switching their
gender in a classroom setting in a
classroom wide what is wrong with this
what what aaron has an issue with this
uh none but they want to demonize it and
call it the don't say gay bill you've
got uh pete buddha judge's husband's
like it's gonna kill gay people what are
they even talking about it's it's so in
another world but of course they don't
want you to read it they don't want to
see how reasonable this is and they
don't want to lose any grip they have on
the education system
they shouldn't be pushing gender
propaganda kindergartners this is all a
fundraising opportunity for the human
rights campaign which has achieved its
goals but still needs to raise money
what a scam and we're all falling
forward i appreciate the clarity of what
you just said chadwick moore thank you
thank you my pleasure hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else